frau bär ist ja auch viele menschen
paulas eben schon angeboren geflüchtet
und das ist ja ein thema das sie bewegt
und worüber sie heute sprechen möchten
genau das liegt uns natürlich insgesamt
als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion aber auch
mir ganz besonders als stellvertreterin
von friedrich merz die zuständig ist für
die frauen für die kinder die zu uns
kommen sehr am herzen und was wirklich
skandalös ist ist dass wir eine
bundesfamilienministerin haben die jetzt
heute nach 120 tagen wo die regierung im
amt ist das erste mal inhaltlich im
ausschuss war sie war einmal anfang des
jahres trifft man keine inhaltlichen
fragen stellt das war eine reine
vorstellungsrunden und heute ging es
dann um themen die meines erachtens in
manchen bereichen themen waren jetzt
vielleicht nicht die mehrheit der
bevölkerung betreffen und als es dann um
die fragestellungen ging wie gehen wir
mit den geflüchteten frauen mit den
geflüchteten kindern um war dann ganz
viel lehrstelle wir haben ja auch die
forderungen dass zum beispiel
schutzzonen an unseren bahnhöfen
eingerichtet werden dass sich die frauen
und die kinder die jugendlichen bei uns
wohlfühlen können fehlanzeige und was
besonders schmerzt ist dass das
offensichtlich auch so eine
wurschtigkeit und auch meines erachtens
einen sei nicht anzunehmen des themas
ist nicht nur bei der
bundesfamilienministerin
sondern auch bei der
bundesverteidigungsminister rinn bei der
bundes innenministerin da ist eine ganz
ganz große leerstelle und deswegen sage
ich an dieser stelle olaf scholz muss
jetzt endlich mal dass seine arbeit
machen wir brauchen einen krisenstab der
den namen auch verdient
ich würde mir auch wünschen er würde
einen ukraine kabinett ein lichten wir
haben das in der letzten regierung zu
ganz vielen themen gehabt wir hatten ein
permanent tagen des digital kabinett wir
hatten aber auch ein brett kabinett wir
hatten aber auch zum beispiel ein klima
kabinett auf wunsch auch der spd und
jetzt gibt es aber keine cabinet obwohl
man eigentlich erwarten müsste das 24 7
alle an einem tisch sitzen die
katastrophen dienste aber auch mit den
ländern regelmäßig gesprochen wird und
ich habe vor ein paar wochen im
ausschuss mal die staatssekretärin weil
wie gesagt die ministerin nicht anwesend
ist gefragt ob denn das
bundesfamilienministerium eingebunden
ist in so einen krisenstab da hieß es
sie telefoniert mit den länderkollegen
einmal die woche und da muss ich ganz
offen sagen dass es zu wenig und die
frauen und die kinder die zu uns kommen
haben jeden schutz verdient und der ist
meines erachtens nicht ausreichend
gegeben
frau bär sie haben gerade angesprochen
dass mehr passieren muss ich habe das
gefühl dass ich vor allem die kommunen
auch alleine gelassen fühlen wo er dann
auch die geflüchteten hinkommen was
könnte man dagegen tun oder möchten sie
vielleicht erklären wie das auch in
deutschland abläuft für den zuschauer na
ja es ist so dass wir natürlich die
arbeit bei den kommunen lassen und man
muss an der stelle auch mal den ganzen
ehrenamtlichen wirklich danken die da
eine ganz ganz große willkommenskultur
haben es ist in jeder das wetter zu
bestätigen unseren kommunen das sind
schulen die sind voll mit den
geflüchteten frauen und kindern das sind
fast alle gemeindesäle die bürgermeister
vor ort die landräte die da ihre arbeit
machen und jetzt geht es natürlich darum
wie können sie jetzt auch eine
integration eine beschulung eine
pädagogik mitbringen für die kinder die
zu uns kommen wir hatten heute gemeinsam
mit friedrich merz auch aus endlos und
auch eine ehemalige parlamentarierin aus
der ukraine ukraine bei uns im deutschen
bundestag die er nach warschau
geflüchtet sind um von polen aus eben
ihrem land zu helfen und die haben auch
darum gebeten dass vor allem die kinder
schnell in die kindergärten kommen in
die kitas kommen in die schulen kommen
aber natürlich auch behutsam das muss
natürlich auch so ein stufenplan sein
dass sie auch erst mal ihre traumata in
den griff bekommen also wir haben
unseren die frauen erzählt dass selbst
die zweijährigen kinder die jetzt nicht
direkt beschossen wurden aber nur
alleine von den sirenen so traumatisiert
sind die sie da auch über wochen oder
über tage und wochen mitbekommen haben
und die kommunen brauchen da einfach
auch bundesweit mal einen plan bis
funktionieren soll sollen sie jetzt
gleich dann auch schon die deutsche
sprache mit erlernen sollen sie
gleichzeitig aber noch die die in den
schulen sind auch in der ukraine
zugeschaltet werden da klappt das ja
ganz gut mit der digitalen bildung wie
sie zugeschaltet werden weil sie halt
auch sagen dass über 72 prozent ihrer
landsleute stand jetzt auch wieder
zurück wollen die wollen auch ihr land
wieder aufbauen und das was sie
angesprochen haben oder was sie auch
genannt wurde von in dem film war auch
der große wunsch der frauen das einfach
mehr waffenlieferungen stattfinden dass
sie sich selber verteidigen dürfen dass
sie ihr land auch wieder aufbauen dürfen
und dass sie aber jetzt natürlich
möchten dass auch die frauen und die
kinder auch registriert werden dass es
auch ganz wichtig weil wir wissen ja
auch gar nicht wie viele im land sind
auch diese registrierung verweigert
die ampel an der stelle die
bundesinnenminister den sagt jammer kann
die gar nicht registrieren weil die
sollen ja auch nicht frieren dann
irgendwie grenze stehen komischerweise
schafft es die polen wesentlich besser
an ihrer grenze sich da zu kümmern und
das ist meines erachtens ein
armutszeugnis und könnte wesentlich
besser gelöst aber ist es nicht ganz
amüsant ich beginne es übrigens zu
genießen vielleicht sollten wir das
öfter machen zwei von ähnlichen parteien
sind wenn ich dieselbe partei aber
herrscht einigen aber nicht dass höhere
die registrierung hat nicht geklappt da
denke ich mir als bürgerin also 2015 war
aber nicht die aktuelle regierung an der
macht haben das nicht sie nicht
hinbekommen also genau ihre regierung
dass im jahr 2015 und auch im jahr 2016
einiges nicht gut gelaufen ist war klar
allerdings hat sich in den letzten
jahren ja auch dann viel getan und es
geht ja jetzt nicht nur um die frage
diejenigen zu schützen also die jetzt zu
uns kommen sondern es war ja auch die
diskussion über die frage müssen wir
nicht eigentlich auch die registrieren
die hier hilfe angeboten haben in den
ersten wochen und wo wir wissen das
natürlich ganz ganz viele mitbürger
guten motiven gekommen sind aber eben
auch zuhälter hier aus berlin am
berliner hauptbahnhof gestanden haben
und gesagt haben
frauen und kinder wir nehmen euch auf
das etwas was ich ganz ganz ganz
furchtbar finde und dass wir es da nicht
geschafft haben zu einer regelung zu
kommen ist fatal und das hätten sie
geschafft also die union hätte das
geschafft da bin ich mir sicher weil aus
den erfahrungen die wir jetzt 15 16
gemacht haben wir in den folgejahren
genau dies dann auch passiert ist was
mir aber noch mal wichtig ist ist dass
wir die kommunen besser unterstützen
weil wenn man sich die flüchtlingszahlen
auch der des letzten jahres angeschaut
haben dann waren die ja nicht bei null
auch im jahr 2021 kamen menschen zu uns
auch da war der wohnraum in meiner
region beispielsweise schon knapp jetzt
kommen über ganz kurze zeit noch mehr
menschen hinzu vor ort redet man man
bestellt container und anderes viel
privater wohnraum wird auch freigegeben
aber hier brauchst eine
gesamtstrategie auch des bundes dass wir
hier die kommunen besser unterstützen
wir haben jetzt zum beispiel schon wenn
ich das noch ergänzen darf zu wenig
kindergartenplätze in vielen bereichen
und jetzt weiß man dass noch viel viel
mehr kinder dazukommen
der plan ist zwar das hat die ampel
heute auch noch mal bestätigt ja wir
wollen das aber es ist jetzt im haushalt
nirgendwo haushalt ethisch hinterlegt
und genau so wie wir es von beiden
pflegerinnen und bei den pflegern
besprochen haben wachsen ja auch
diejenigen die im kindergarten arbeiten
nicht auf den bäumen also da wurde
erzieherinnen so bekommen das sind in
der regel ja auch frauen
die übrigens mit ganz ganz lange
ausbildung machen auch mit fünf jahren
das ist ja auch nicht von ungefähr und
die plätze braucht man aber jetzt da
muss man dann auch kreativer unterwegs
sein und jetzt schon sagte mit einführen
und sie wie gesagt dann auch zur
versuchung wäre klären ich hoffe du
nimmst mich übrig für die gern noch mal
bei der registrierung der flüchtlinge
bleiben weil dafür nicht ganz spannend
dass ausgerechnet cdu csu und cdu das
heute anbringen sebastian als
politikredakteur vom bild wie hast du
das beobachtet auch in den letzten
jahren der registrierung von
flüchtlingen ist es ein neues ampel
problem also wir müssen ja ganz nüchtern
konstatieren dass 2015 folgende aufgrund
des eingehen ich kann wenn es der
bundesregierung da sehe ich frau merkel
damals in der verantwortung sich aber
auch ihren parteikollegen herrn seehofer
in der verantwortung die beiden haben
sich dass intern behagt richtig bei
rausgekommen ist aber nichts dass wir
einen massiven zuzug hatten auch von
menschen die tatsächlich eben keine
flüchtlinge waren und die die
gelegenheit genutzt haben wie ins land
zu kommen und da ist viel zu lange
nichts gemacht worden und wenn jetzt
frau feser die jetzige in ministerin so
etwas möglicherweise wiederholt in dem
sie in dem sich jetzt gesagt eine
registrierung findet sich nicht in
ordnung man muss doch erst mal alle
reihen lassen und so um sich das
wiederholt dann glaube ich erleben wir
dass wir schon wieder riskieren dass die
hilfsbereitschaft dann sehr schnell ans
ende bekommt und ich glaube auch
tatsächlich es ist noch nicht erkannt
worden welcher dimension wir es hier zu
tun haben wir ja millionen ukrainer
frauen und kinder vor allem auf der
flucht sind und das wird uns auch
gesellschaftlich eine unglaubliche
anstrengung und unglaubliche leistung
abverlangen diese situation